[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
كوكب الارض صح
يسموها البصمه
اي نشاط بيعمل فيديو يا ايامي ياثر في
البيئه الحوالينا
[موسيقى]
علميا يستخدم للفخذ الاجتماعي العربي
الحاجات الايجابيه اللي انت ممكن تعملها
عشان احنا نمشي قدامنا والبصمه تكون
ايجابيا
المحليه وفي مصيبه لانه في عمليه الاطعمه
هي بصمه سلبيه على على حوالين
الزريعه السوداني بتفهم
القسم الاول
[موسيقى]
لو سمعت التعاليق السودانيه
العكس
السبب الرئيسي للمبارك
[موسيقى]
كنت عايز الحضاره
يعني قبل خمس سته سبعه سنوات
والكلام
سلبي
وكده
عاداتنا القديمه الواحد قال له
بتساوي البترول ثلاثه شهور
اضافيه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
الموضوع ده
بالنسبه بالنسبه لك يعني
الانترنت
لموضوع العلف قليله سهله قديمه
الموضوع
بهذا السنين
[موسيقى]
مختلفه شويه عشان ادق على
ابحاث من الموضوع عن ناحيه
اللي هي
[موسيقى]
المراره
تكلفه الفتان من التغطيه الحيوان
تحتاج اليات
بتاع اليومي في ميزات مهتمه
المهنيه
العدد لكن غالي
ه 15 20 الف دولار عشان تتمنى
انا
منزليه بعد الحاجات اللي عاملاها الخطوات
اللي انا عملتها
لكن بالبرنامج يعني بدون اي امكانيات
عاليه لكن النتيجه بردو المياه زي الحاجه
العالميه
[موسيقى]
هو عباره عن بذور فيها معينه من
الاضاءه
البهايم
اسمها شعيب
فكان الفكر
النبات البذور الموجوده
[موسيقى]
فكانت مغني جدا جدا
بصوره كبيره لكن
الدلال الكبير اللي شفناها دي غالي جدا
جدا زي ما عايز
اشوف
محليه عشان تكون
شاركنا في الحب وذلك
في المرحله الثانيه لكن
[موسيقى]
انه لاعب ناخذ
المباراه الثاني
لكن على الباب
الموضوع
القديم
[موسيقى]
يعني اسمها
المعجزه
[موسيقى]
كل ما كان
حسابات حسابات الفدان
بيطلع فن منها يوميا
الموضوع ده
في السودان
وبديت انا
فيها شنو والزيارات
[موسيقى]
في البيت
وبديت حتى الناس منشورين
الحاجات اللي
[موسيقى]
نفسي
في البيت
بنصف تقريبا من النبات يوميا بدون
تجارب منزليه كانت
ممكن الان نزول
ممكن تنتهي ويوم
من الفوضى مجال
[تصفيق]
تنميه
الثوره الحيوانيه في الولايات السودان
المتابعين عندهم عملت
ايه في في الزراعه
للناس
المعروف في ناس بيحطوا
معمول السبب
الاسماك
منوفر عليهم
[موسيقى]
السوداني ينشا
ايمان
الحصول على المعلومات الزراعيه اللي انا
عاوزها ويجيب نفس القاعده اللي حصل
تحول استخراج المعلومات السلام
العيد والمعلومه
بدات الزراعه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
فممكن بشكل مو مشكله
ببساطه
المنزليه بغرض الارتفاع الذاتي
موسع عن
تزيد دخلت من خلال متر مربع في
هشام مسح المنزل ثلاثه
[تصفيق]
مع خطيبي مسجد اسمه محمد يوسف العربي هو
كامله عن
الريانه
تستطيع الضفه كامله عن الزراعه
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله نهايه
الناس تطلع
[موسيقى]
البراز
قبل كده حاجه
مباشره بدون دخول دخول المسطحه عندنا اكثر
من 100 مزارع متوصلين معهم يجيبوا
موضوع الافات المدارس في في الاحياء عن
الزراعه
المدرسيه وش
[تصفيق]